i remember
about a year ago
i was interviewing rupert spyra
and i was asking him
about biometrics
of awakening
using heart rate variability
and eeg
and fmri data
to show these scientific
physicalism correlates to enlightenment
and although there is some good data
there
rupert responded by saying
we should look to the degree of
imperturbable peace
and causeless joy
one experiences
as markers for
awakening
and although i had my tastes
a year ago
[Music]
uh there's nothing quite like
the endless
waterfall that is
what is experienced now a year later
[Music]
complete causeless
joy
reading sachit ananda
existence consciousness bliss truth
consciousness bliss
over and over again
studying it for two
three dozen times over the last couple
of years
but like studying it like a scholar
[Laughter]
like a scholar
millennia
of vedic rishis
and adi shankara
there's a massive difference between
like a scholar
reading about such ananda versus
experientially
feeling the well of honey
[Laughter]
as sri aurobindo and the mother mira
alfassa
said under the rock
the well of honey under the rock
ah
so much peace
unshakable imperturbable cellular
equanimity
so relaxing
and then the realization that
a year ago i was wondering
why does the west
have this problem with enlightenment
why does it have this problem with
awakening why does it have this problem
with non-duality
why does it take people
that feel causeless joy and why does it
put them
into hospitalization
into insane asylums
into mental health clinics
and now i get it
it's the bliss police
the bliss police the bliss
police the matrix agents
are knocking at your door knock knock
hello we are the bliss police we have
heard that you've tapped into the well
of
honey under the rock that is
causeless joy and imperturbable peace
and that is
not allowed in our western economic
machinery
please give us your wrists so we may put
the golden handcuffs on and ship you
back into the economic machinery
in a suit and tie and a briefcase
so that you may partake in more wall
street transactions
what a joke what a joke
just the contrasting difference
between cnn and
fox news versus
people talking about becoming aware of
awareness
and becoming aware of infinity and
becoming
aware of themselves as the creator
just the contrast between those
is hilarious
one of them is the matrix
one of them captivates
consciousness and turns it into a slave
the left are a bunch of idiots no the
right is a bunch of idiots
they're both bunch of idiots everyone is
a bunch of idiots
this politician will do everything
that they promise to do this politician
promises that they're gonna do
everything
it's so sticky
it's so captivating for consciousness is
so
polarizing and propagandic
and there's the juxtaposition between
that
stickiness the bliss police
and becoming aware of awareness
becoming aware of oneself as the creator
becoming aware
of one's infinitude
and then there's this
also just
this sadness also that comes from
realization that
that is you you are that which
creates the matrix and then liberates
yourself from the matrix
and that there is so much of you that is
still
in the stickiness of politicians
and propaganda and economic machinery
and matrix agents and bliss police
and all of that and then you're like the
children
the children liberate the children let
them
play liberate the children let them play
don't ship the children into suits
and ties with briefcases focusing on
wall street transactions
i must attain this sheet of paper
in order to have financial security for
the rest
of my life i want
white picket fence i want
suburban house please
sign me up for 30
mortgage
what no
children innocent
children no
[Music]
the story we created here
as this creation is so funny it's so
[Music]
perfect
to taste
that
unleashes that well of honey
that is the causeless joy that is the
imperturbable peace
and it's great to butterfly effect
the causeless joy
it's really beautiful when you bring
the causeless joy out
as is said in the tantric tradition you
weave
your awakened realizations into
the social fabric and when you do so you
begin
bringing this causeless joy
and imperturbable peace out and
people respond there is a little bit of
bliss police
but generally people
undergo mimesis where there's a
very clear copying
and repeating so when you come with this
causeless joy and you're like
hi and you're just like
super happy then they're like
hey and they also smile
and even if somebody's feeling a little
bit kind of like
neutral and then you come with your
radiating sunlight glow
then they're like
and they increase themselves from
neutral to joyful
and it's so nice
like those tiny
increases from neutral to joyful
are the whole point of sunlight that's
the whole point of causeless joy
the whole point of it is that the sun
just radiates love and light and doesn't
expect
anything in return
and so it radiates out butterfly effects
out
that causeless joy without expecting
anything in return and it moves somebody
from a more
neutral state to a hmm okay i'll be a
little happier
and then that's like nice
not the children oh that part
it's true though it definitely
prevent the children from becoming
matrix agents
this is the natural state
[Laughter]
hmm
existence consciousness bliss
it's just covered by a rock
and the cosmic joke is that the rock is
an illusion
the rock is an illusion
that's why roomie is goat greatest of
all time
but we go from room to room looking for
the diamond that's already around our
neck
the well of honey is there we
artificially create
a rock this egoic contraction
separate finite attachment to
form an identity
and then we liberate ourselves
through that veilless veil that gateless
gate
whoo we pop the bubbleless bubble
the well of honey was there the whole
time
the diamond was there the whole time my
gosh when the nervous system
realizes that the diamond was there the
whole time
it just like goes into shock it's like
what
it was there the whole time i've been
seeking
externally for my nature
i've been trying to attain peace and
happiness
in objects and experiences and
relationships and substances
and then you [ __ ] laugh at yourself
because you're like
i was so stupid just like in the parable
of the prodigal son
i was so dumb thinking that i would
find peace and happiness
in a dream in an illusion
when in reality the nature of the
[ __ ] observer
itself is peace and happiness
that's the realization that's the cosmic
joke
ah
and then the cosmic joke
also deepens with
wondering well who created this reality
why am i here what is my nature
and then you realize as you
externalize god you externalize the
absolute
i i this person this
finite person cannot possibly be
the absolute
how silly oh my gosh
the kingdom of god is within you
the kingdom of god within you
the kingdom of god within you
the kingdom of god within you
luke 17 21
you are that you are the absolute
i am the absolute you are the absolute
we
are the absolute this
right here is the absolute
this is that
what ah
relax relax
breathe
and you can tell over the last
two years we've been getting
these comments on our channel oh
that guy what substance is eon that guy
what substance is he on right because
that's how the west has been programmed
the west is programmed into thinking
that oh if somebody
is feeling causeless joy and
imperturbable peace
they must be on a psychedelic or
entheogen
no dude that is literally what the east
with nonduality has been talking about
for millennia
go and read up about it and then
eventually experience it
directly
and then you're so liberated you're so
relaxed
relaxed
ah because you're safe
you're safe the causeless
joy can emerge like a waterfall
because you know you're safe you know
this is your own creation
you are the absolute
you are expressing yourself as this
creation
and you know you're safe you know
you are that
and then this
emerges recognizes
as the natural state
the very inhalations and exhalations
themselves
the very observation the very witnessing
the very
awareness itself that is
shared that's impersonal that's eternal
that in itself is causeless joy
the natural state is this
the labyrinth of our own creation
we did a pretty good job with this one i
gotta say
we did a really good job with this one
this is one of the most intense
creations
not the children don't strip the sachet
ananda away
don't hide it mercilessly
indoctrinating them into the machine of
the matrix
it's a really strong matrix machine
it takes a lot of courage to liberate
oneself from that matrix machine
ruthless ruthless
there are still some indigenous
traditions around the planet that
because children are raised right into
that
infinity there's no
formation even of that feeling of
finite separation
so the causeless joy the eternity the
infinity
never has the illusion of the rock form
in the first place
and also in the vedic tradition
it's talked about like hallucinating
a snake when it's just a rope
it's just a rope and we hallucinate it
as a snake
oh i'm so unsafe i'm so unsafe
no you're safe this is your own creation
you designed this labyrinth yourself
as an escape room for yourself
to break free from
fooled into separation by our own
creation
fooled into separation by our own
creation
fooled into separation by our own
creation
fooled into separation by our own
creation hey
there's only one there's
only one infinite
eternal intelligence
present joyfully
blissfully peacefully
lovingly wisely
at play with itself
endlessly as these creations
you are on an endless river
and the river is an illusion
you're [ __ ] hilarious
liberate the children liberate the
children let them taste
the causeless joy it's their birthright
let them taste the causeless joy
liberate
ourselves from the matrix from the
economic machine
let them taste their true nature
i must earn money because i am
unsafe let me get this sheet of paper
and this 30-year
mortgage maybe i will get a wife or a
husband and that will make me
happy
oh my gosh it's so
algorithmic it's so scripted
[Music]
wow
almost as though causeless joy and
imperturbable peace
feel like algorithms
that only exist for
the small percentage
of the population that liberates
themselves
from the robotic algorithmic
scripts of the economic matrix
do you watch cnn because i do
do you watch fox news because i do
the other is looney tunes
when you don't know that the other
is actually the same infinite creator
that's where all of your suffering
arises
i'm a separate entity and you are a
separate entity and we are just eight
billion separate entities on this random
planet that we didn't create
what do you mean causeless joy i need
alcohol to be joyous i need cannabis to
be
joyous i need a ferrari to be joyous
i need a house to be joyous
i need a nice watch that i can show off
to people to be
joyous you see
where all of the suffering and all of
the misery happens
i need a relationship to be joyous
i need a nine-to-five job to be joyous
cause less joy
causeless joy imperturbable
peace nothing can
perturb your peace cellular equanimity
your nature is the well of honey
and the rock is just an illusion
it's just us hallucinating a snake
when there is none it's just a [ __ ]
rope
this is all your creation
you're not a victim
you're the creator
you're not a victim you're the
creator
now create yourself a trajectory away
from the matrix
and towards causeless joy an imperturbal
peace
that the mystics have talked about for
millennia
mysticism is yoga which means
union with what with a god with absolute
that's it
and when you unite
that's when you feel that the natural
state
has been there the whole time
hahaha cosmic joke
cosmic joke natural states been there
the whole time
oh a year later
here we are and i finally get it
i get what rupert meant
a year ago by causalis
joy
thank you
liberate the children liberate them